what factors into you saying yes to a
project
and what factors into you saying no let
me limit my answer to a
narrative to scripted narrative because
you know there's so many
other manifestations but
the one thing i would say is that it's
just got to be a great script
you know i've i've learned the hard way
that that no amount of talent behind or
in front of the camera no amount of
money can compensate for a bad script
meanwhile you can take a really really
good script
and and have shabby technical values and
still have a really
entertaining movie so i look at what i
do
as as window dressing you know and i
think it's
important of course but but
if i don't have the skeleton to hang my
pretty pictures on then it's just gonna
be
vacuous so the first thing is that is
that i want to see
a good script the other thing is that i
want to know
that these people have enough money to
do justice to that script
you know i'm not going to be biased if
you come at me with
you know 10 million dollars or if you
come at me with 200
000 as long as you can do a good job on
your script
with that money if you're being
unrealistic to me that's like
buying a ticket on the titanic and i do
not want to go down with it because i'll
be blamed
you know if there aren't the resources
for the crew
if there aren't enough days if there are
unrealistic expectations
if there are tons of visual effects and
not enough money to pay for them
it's going to look like crap and my
name's going to be on it i don't care
how much they pay me
i'm not going to do it um
so so you know a good script and the
ability to do a good job with it
um and then i look at the collaborators
you know who
is the director who is the producer who
are the other keys the production
designer
who's the talent you know the the cast
and if there are people i'm excited to
work about if they've done
or if i'm if there are people i'm
excited to work with
if they've done good work if i know them
you know if they give me a really
compelling pitch
i mean all of that you know can
can play to getting me excited um
and um you know just like with the money
i wouldn't know that they have enough
time i don't want them to tell me
they're going to do a movie in three
days
you know because that's again i probably
should have said resource instead of
money i
just want to make sure they have the
resources enough money enough crew
enough time and that's not saying you
have to have a ton of
any of those things you don't have to
have a ton of money you don't have to
have a
ton of crew or a ton of days but you
know you can't have
a shoot with three location moves in a
day
and two crew people and you know it's
just
unless you're shooting guerrilla style
in which case i mean that's a legitimate
form of filmmaking but
for me as a cinematographer what does
that do for me i mean does that
show anything that i want to show there
are some dp's who will embrace that
because that's their jam and that's
wonderful but for me i'm a very you know
painterly and interactive i mean i want
to
affect the image and if i don't feel i'm
you know if i feel
to me that would be damage control if
there's too many location moves and it's
just like set up an exposure
set up the camera focus get an exposure
shoot move
i'm like where's the creativity for me
and that
you know again somebody else maybe it's
there
but for me i don't necessarily feel it's
and i might be wrong somebody might
pitch me a movie and convince me oh yeah
here
you know you can do it this way in that
way again this is the whole
malleable thinking i mean i'm okay well
i would i would break that rule because
you've convinced me
but just as a general thing i want to
see that i can
practically achieve something i'm going
to be proud to put my name on
and won't be embarrassed by um and then
you know the last thing is
is money you know i mean um
is it a friend asking me to come help
out on a weekend
is it a movie asking me to go
to brazil and shoot for two months um
you know what is it and so uh you know i
would i would i would consider that and
if it's something i really really want
to do well i at least have to make
enough to make my bills you know um
but ideally you know we want to make
enough to have some savings and
and have fun and especially when i do
travel jobs you know i like
i like bringing you know kathy with me
and
um or you know and then we have some
vacation days and
um you know like if we go to canada or
or
you know wherever um just you know turn
it into a little
mini holiday because most of the
traveling i've been all over the world
i've been to every continent except
antarctica
and um it's 95
work travel and what i do is i'll build
in extra days you know i'll stay a
little
longer or i'll go early or you know if
there's a break in the middle but i turn
it into these little vacations and you
know
it's just super fun have you ever turned
down
work and then when you looked back on it
realized
maybe it was a mistake oh yes i have a
great story
and this is a money thing too and it
goes the opposite way of what i've been
saying
so yeah i had a friend of mine
a casting director who i really got
along with and he had cast some movies
that i
shot and he
pitched me he said you know don
coscarelli the guy who did
phantasm is uh doing a horror movie
and it's a horror comedy and and they
would like you
to shoot it and it was this movie called
bubba hotep
um and i thought well that sounds fun
because you know i like ancient egypt
and i like horror and i like comedy
and um they called me up and we talked
and i said oh that's great
and they said you know what's the rate
and they said 400 and i'm like okay 400
a day i can you know i can make that
work um
and i said okay yeah four hundred
dollars a day is fine and they said no
it's four hundred dollars a week
and and either this was right when i was
starting music videos
or right before but anyway i was making
a lot of money at the time
and i'm just like i'm just like i just
can't i can't see that happening you
know and i turned it down and i was
fine with that well turned out that they
cast bruce campbell and aussie davis in
it
you know two amazing legendary actors
and it's a cult classic and and
and i just kick myself i'm like oh my
god i wish i had done that movie
you know i just in retrospect i don't
give a i would have done it for
free
um but but you just never know
i mean i've i've done movies that i took
a chance on and then they came out
crappy
um i don't know i
hey that was that's just my experience
that was
that was one that i wish i had made a
different decision but
but when i looked at the cards on the
table they just didn't make sense
you